this is it this aspirant we can get to
the beans let's get to me Oh sir Oh God
what are we gonna do there was this guy
who cooked his girlfriend and I - I
can't cuz I envy you nice okay before we
go we got to do human friend speed yeah
what is a human friend paid if the photo
we always take that's like the movie
human centipede where they're sewn
together mouth to anus but it's with
friends so it's special eye in the
middle oh how do you want the middle
this is it your Bachelorette weekend we
have been dreaming about this moment
it's the first day of freshman year
we're going to be swimming and big girl
I just got a call from The busboy why
everyone's at jung joonyoung I was kind
of hoping that we could make it an early
night
this doesn't feel right yeah I don't
think so baby girl
[Music]
[Applause]
growling [ __ ] pouches oh my god I'm
so hot baby got you so now you got too
much makeup not jamming for your face
let's get this stripper
male or female though ma'am I think male
for her fine I can feel special oh no no
no come on do you want to do I know you
get the picture alone when you're
totally [ __ ] take my picture stay with
this guy in Australia who cooked his
girlfriend and I to you I can't because
I am vegan bye
[Music]
don't be the best weekend of our parking
lot I probably had HPV now whenever we
all have HPV I don't have HPV if you've
had sex after be in 1991 then you do
have HPV oh then I have like a [ __ ] ton
of HPV consequence of it okay
[Music]
you